bathroom law and then columnist for
Halle politics Indiana
Craig done on Tuesday's Republican
Indiana primary and now the Cruz Kasich
Alliance is playing out in the Hoosier
State be sure to watch these bands
Washington Journal beginning live at
7:00 a.m. Eastern Monday morning
join the discussion tonight on c-span
Q&A with journalist Amy Goodman that's
followed by British Prime Minister David
Cameron taking questions from members of
the House of Commons later Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
talks about the current delegate count
and his campaign moving forward at a
news conference in Washington
[Music]
this week on Q&A Democracy Now hosts an
executive producer Amy Goodman she talks
about some of the stories and people
democracy now is covered over the past
20 years
[Music]
Amy Goodman 20 years of democracy now
and you say going to where the silence
is as your motto explain that well
unfortunately the corporate media leaves
such a gap to cover the majority of
people in this country and around the
world mean when you turn to the
network's
they have this small circle of pundits
who know so little about so much
explaining the world to us and getting
it so wrong the idea of democracy now
starting 20 years ago it really hasn't
changed bringing out the voices of
people at the grassroots in the United
States and around the world and they
very represent I think the majority of
people I mean I think people who are
concerned deeply about war and peace
about the growing inequality in this
country about climate change the fate of
the planet are not a fringe minority not
even a silent majority but the silenced
majority silenced by the corporate media
which is why we have to take it back 20
years ago in February we had you as a
guest on our Morning Show here's a clip
four days after you started Democracy
Now you got to ask Amy Goodman about
this piece and in Karl's ends monsters
magazine white liberals find talk radio
so threatening and you're a talk-show
host and not and not a conservative
that's right well I we just started a
show this week on Pacific a radio called
Democracy Now which is the only
grassroots national daily election show
bringing the voice of the grassroots
into the national political discourse I
haven't even read the article why
liberals fine talk radio so threatening
I find talk radio I haven't I don't get
to hear a lot of talk radio because I'm
doing a lot myself but I think a lot of
what we're hearing what I'm reading
about what's being said
is a lot of hate-mongering what's the
difference between democracy now
one-hour program you do every day today
then what it was like back 20 years ago
well first of all we were on nine
community radio stations in 1996 and by
the way Brian when you invited me on we
started in Washington DC at the Pacifica
radio station there WPF W I thought
you've gotten the wrong number I mean
that was the first time I was ever
invited on television it was four days
after our first broadcast February 19
1996 and it was really remarkable but in
a sense the mission hasn't changed that
was 20 years ago on nine stations now
we're broadcasting on over 1400 not only
community radio stations but public
radio stations and PR stations on public
access TV stations around the country on
PBS TV stations around the country and
also all over the world we broadcast on
television and radio in Sweden and Japan
and South Africa throughout Latin
America our headlines are translated
into Spanish for the Spanish speaking us
audience as well as people around the
planet and I think the growth from nine
stations to 1400 is a testament to the
hunger for independent voices people on
the ground we're deeply involved in
their communities not having the pundits
on describing experiences they often
don't know about but people themselves
that's just plain old hard work and I
want to just pay tribute to all the
remarkable producers and journalists and
videographers who have worked at
Democracy Now because it's that digging
every day to bring people to a global
audience who are speaking in their own
words there is nothing more powerful I
mean the we're on television and radio
equal number at the time we started on
Pacifica and it's really instructive to
look at Pacifica's history founded in
1949 Berkeley California
a war resistor named Lew Hill came out
of the detentions camps and said there's
got to be a media outlet that's not run
by corporations that profit from war but
run by journalists and artists and
that's how Pacifica was born as george
gerbner the late Dean of the Annenberg
of School of Communications at the
University of Pennsylvania said not run
by corporations that have nothing to
tell and everything to sell that are
raising our children today and so the
first station was KPFA in Berkeley in 49
the second station KPFK in Los Angeles
in 1959 my station here in New York is
WBAI 1961 in the year 1977 WPF W in
Washington in a 1970 KPFT in Houston and
that station is the only radio station
in the country you know in the Petro
Metro Houston Texas that was blown off
the air by the Ku Klux Klan it was only
months and two weeks into its operation
when the Klan strapped dynamite to the
base of the transmitter and blew it to
smithereens so when they got back on
their feet I think he blew it up in the
middle of our logo three singing alice's
restaurant they got back on their feet
rebuilt the transmitter and the Klan
strapped 15 times the dynamite to the
base of the transmitter and blew it up
again so now it's a national event when
they finally go back to the air I think
it was January of 1971 now PBS was
covering the return of the KPFT to the
airways Arlo Guthrie came back into
Houston to finish alice's restaurant the
song and I can't remember if it was the
exalted Cyclops or the Grand Dragon
because I often confuse their titles but
he said it was his proudest act I think
that's because he understood how
dangerous independent media can be
dangerous because it allows people to
speak for themselves and when you hear
someone speaking from their own
experience whether it is a Palestinian
child or an Israeli grandmother whether
it's an Iraqi uncle and aunt in
Afghanistan whether it's a child in the
South Bronx or in Ferguson Missouri that
breaks down
area types and caricatures that fuel the
hate groups that's why it's the threat I
think the media can be the greatest
force for peace on earth instead all too
often it's wielded as a weapon of war
and that's why we have to take it back
here you are in 2008 it's a Republican
National Convention and in Minnesota
let's watch this and get you to tell us
a story
why the confrontation well this was the
first day of the Republican convention
of 2008 we had just flown in from Denver
that was the Democratic convention there
was major protests there too against war
so then we came in to st. Paul and on
the first day before the night of the
convention it was a beautiful blueSky
day ten thousand people marched for
peace in fact they were led by men and
women in uniform and they were taking
great risk they were soldiers who'd
returned home who felt that war was not
the answer and many civilians of course
thousands of people so we covered that
protest then I went to the convention
floor with Rick Carelli who would later
you know be an oscar-nominated film
maker with Jeremy Scahill film dirty
wars but we were covering the convention
floor and I was interviewing I remember
people from the hottest state from
Alaska right this is the Sarah Palin
John McCain convention can I get a call
on the cell phone from our senior
producer Mike Burke he said come quickly
to 7th and Jackson this is in st. Paul I
didn't know the area Nicole and Sharif
have been arrested now Nicole Salazar
and truffaut boca do swear our two
reporters who when we had finished
covering the protests they went to the
public access TV station where we were
broadcasting from to digitize tape and I
said but they were in the TV station
well they had seen there was a protest
outside and they had gone downstairs to
cover it and he said they've been
bloodied by the police and arrested so
Rick and I raced through the streets of
st. Paul we got to 7th and Jackson and I
saw this line of riot police that you
were just showing and I went up to them
you know I had all my credentials on I
have you know the top security clearance
credentials that allow you to interview
presidents vice presidents I was on the
floor of the convention and I said I
want to speak to your commanding officer
you've got a part of that in this two of
our reporters Sharif and Nicole have
been arrested they're inside than this
parking lot area and I need to have them
released that's why I was standing there
and it wasn't minutes before they pulled
me through the police line pushed me
against a car pulled my arms behind my
back
slapped the hand
son and then push me to the ground they
charged me with interfering with a peace
officer if only there was a peace
officer in the vicinity I'm still
desperately looking from my vantage
point on the ground for a Sharif and
Nicole who I heard were hurt and
arrested and I saw a Sharif across the
parking light I demanded to be brought
to him they finally did though I stolen
handcuffs so we're both standing there
his arm is bleeding with our handcuffs
on with our credentials and so we're
saying we are journalists we want you to
release us now and then the Secret
Service came over and ripped the
credentials from around our necks I'm
taken into the police wagon there I see
Nicole whose face has been bloodied I
said Nicole what happened how did you
get arrested and she said we were in the
TV studio we saw right outside riot
police and protesters we ran down with
our video camera and microphone just
start recording they would not have been
doing their jobs if they just stayed in
the TV studio so they're in this parking
lot and she was against parked cars and
the riot police came at her I mean this
was a completely contained area at this
point and they were shouting on your
face and they were saying that she had
to move but she said where where she's
against Park cars she didn't know what
hit her from behind her and in front of
her they came and they took her down the
first thing to go down was the camera
tumbled down the first thing they did
was take the battery out of her camera
if they if you want to know what they
wanted to stop happening they're
recording they had their near boot in
her back and her face in the ground and
they're starting to drag her which means
they are her face is being dragged along
the ground Sharif is telling them to
calm down and they take him and they
throw him up against the wall they kick
him twice in the chat they punch him
twice in the chest and they take him
down so his arm is bleeding
they faced felony riot charges so I'm
taken to the police garage where they've
erected cages to put the protesters in
and schrieffer Nicola taken to jail now
I didn't know it was happening at the
time but there was such an outcry at our
arrest and hundreds if not thousands of
people were faxing calling emailing the
authorities to have us released and a
number of hours later we were ultimately
released first Nathan Sharif and Nicole
so then I was brought back
to the convention center it was over for
the night but I was brought into the NBC
skybox and I was being interviewed and
when that was finished an NBC reporter
came over and said I don't get it uh
why wasn't I arrested I said oh were you
covering the protest too and he said no
I said well that's the thing I don't get
arrested in the skybox either I mean
it's our job not only to be in the
skyboxes but to get into the corporate
Suites who's sponsoring these
celebrations of democracy you know the
Republicans and the Democrats and also
to be on the convention floor interview
the delegates and get out into the
streets where the uninvited guests are
and there are often thousands of them
they have something important to say as
well and it's our job to get it all
I mean democracy is a messy thing but we
shouldn't have to get a record when we
put things on the record so that's what
happened to us at the convention we
would later sue the st. Paul and the
Minneapolis police as well as the Secret
Service now interestingly the only
reason knew we knew it was the Secret
Service who pulled our credentials is
that when I turn to the police officer I
said this is outrageous that you've just
pulled our credentials he said it wasn't
us it was a Secret Service so we sued
and the Secret Service wanted to be
separated from the lawsuit first of all
they didn't want to be known that they
were you know there and that they did
this there's all levels of authority at
these what are called special national
security events and but we felt it's
very critical to send a message that
journalists must be protecting all
illegal arrests should not happen
ultimately it took a number of years we
want a six-figure settlement but when we
got out it was right before the next
convention we felt it was very important
to send a message and part of it was
that the st. Paul police would be
trained in dealing with journalists and
so we thought well where do we hold the
news conference announcing that this
settlement has been made and we just
come from st. Paul the settlement
negotiations so when we went to a large
gathering of police and protesters we
went to Zuccotti Park this was in the
middle of Occupy Wall Street we thought
well there a lot of police will be and
they'll hear
and we'll send out this message them
that I mean you cannot simply arrest
journalists because they don't want you
just they don't want because you don't
want them to see you don't want the
public to see what's going on I mean we
live in a democracy and journalism is
extremely important there is a reason
why our profession journalism is the
only one explicitly protected by the US
Constitution because we're supposed to
be the check and balance on power I want
to run a clip of a man named Alex Jones
who could probably not think any more
different than you do based in Texas has
his own radio operation but he's saying
somewhat of the same thing you're saying
about the corporate media again let's
run it and get your reaction to this
I've got 30 employees and I'm not
exaggerating that infowars.com I mean go
to the major stat analytics sites is
dwarfing MSNBC and all of Glenn Beck and
Rush Limbaugh sites combined one website
that's got about six people working on
it they just have all the flash and so
it's a giant hoax and they know people
are looking behind the curtain now that
the emperor has no clothes and so they
are openly announcing internet tracking
internet taxes the White House regulates
regulations are Cass Sunstein has called
for banning quote conspiracy theorists
that's anybody that questions the
official story so the system is losing
credibility it's circling the wagons
with government and the big six mega
corporations to try to start curtailing
alternative media because we are kicking
their hind end are you worried that
somebody's gonna kick your hind end and
take you out of business I think that
the corporate media has to change its
ways and they've learned it I don't
think I mean both with newspapers and
with television I don't think it's just
that they're losing audience because of
the internet they have for a long time
been gatekeepers preventing most views
most people from being heard I think
this year with this presidential
election has so shown so much I mean the
shock
of those on the network TV TV stations
when they see thousands of people coming
out for example for Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders who's very much
expressing the views of people for
example who came to Occupy Wall Street
and other encampments around the country
who were deeply concerned about the
growing inequality between rich and poor
and also who was profiting I mean what
the recent study that shows something
like 62 63 of the richest people in the
world I think something like 42 or 43 of
them are Americans have more wealth than
three and a half billion people than
half the planet this is just astounding
and when Occupy Wall Street happened I
mean the media hardly paid attention at
first but then mocked it and then when
the police eviscerated these encampments
that it's all over what did they
represent anyway they had every they
represented every issue under the Sun
and where were their leaders anyway well
in a sense it was not so much a leader
less but a leader full movement and yes
they represented many different issues
because people were so frustrated with
the direction that this country was
going and I think that we're seeing
these movements on the ground
percolating and coming together and
coalescing I mean President Obama was
elected in 2008 many different movements
came together to elect him first and
foremost I think the peace movement
because I think that's the reason he was
the Democratic candidate the difference
between him and Hillary Clinton was that
she was for the war in Iraq and he was
against the war then there was the
environmental movement racial justice
economic justice movement gay and
lesbian movement all of these different
movements together now they accomplished
something historic the first
african-american president this country
has ever known which is absolutely
astounding with a country with a legacy
of slavery but when it came to the
issues of these different movements you
know ending war dealing with climate
change deal
with the inequality people I think at
that point they felt they had
accomplished something so momentous they
were either exhausted or they didn't
want to contribute to the racist
backlash like the birther movement
something that Donald Trump was one of
the leaders of but the suggestion that
Oh President Obama look at what he looks
like he couldn't come from here and it's
so ridiculous but not just ridiculous it
was racist and people didn't want to
contribute to that backlash and so I
think there was a fear of criticism but
one of his first promises was to close
Guantanamo which became such a symbol
and even he admits recruiting tool for
groups like the self-proclaimed Islamic
state and others and yet what seven
years into his presidency still
Guantanamo stands and though the
Congress has not helped there are a
number of executive actions he could
have taken along the way to ensure that
this you know extra outside of the reach
of US law but run by the United States
prison would be closed
astounding most recently that President
Obama was in Cuba the first president is
sitting president and eighty-eight years
to go and he's talking to the Cuban
President Raul Castro about human rights
yet just down the road I mean if the
u.s. is presenting a model a little
corner of Cuba the u.s. does lease land
and what does it do with it it's got
Guantanamo where ninety one men still
languish many approved for release for
decades even back to the Bush
administration many held for more than a
decade without charge it is a very
painful lesson what the US has come to
represent to the rest of the world what
do you think somebody has to do in order
to label themselves a journalist and as
you know you've got very strong views
and there's never any doubt what you
think but couldn't just anybody in our
society say I'm a journalist and I want
credentials and I should have access to
everything I mean I think the whole
citizen journalism movement and non
citizen journalists movement has been
extremely important because for so long
the mainstream media
didn't go to places on the ground they
had that elite group of pundits and so
they were missing so much of the story I
mean I think about Ferguson now the
network's did go to Ferguson to their
credit this is after Michael Brown was
killed by Darren Wilson the police
officer and they showed people being
tear gassed they showed the
militarization of police but even with
that there was not a lot of showing not
the political leaders but the people in
the crowds often I remember watching CNN
one day and one of the journalists I
think it was at a protest in New York
was walking along with the protesters
and saying you know now we're going up
44th Street we're turning on this street
we're turning on that Street and to his
credit in the middle of the protesters
but they were a backdrop
they were the scenery for his giving
basically a traffic report and now we're
moving up this street necessary what
about handing the mic to them I mean it
is that going behind the scenes and
truly talking to people on the ground so
often you'll have the network's calling
us and saying who is that person who is
this person I mean the amazing movements
that had reshaped America like the black
lives matter movement three
african-american women who coined this
term black lives matter who deeply
committed to racial justice in this
country making sure that the microphones
open up and the way the black lives
matter movement has grabbed attention
they're not waiting for the network's to
come to them and interview them and
we're talking about decentralized
movement all over this country right
they're going to they went to martin
O'Malley's rallies they go into Bern
Bernie Sanders rallies they went to
Hillary Clinton rallies and they
interrupted and it wasn't just the
Republicans it was the Democrats say how
are you addressing our issues and
they've really changed the shape of
presidential politics in 2016 what would
you say though to Republicans some
Republicans I have no idea how the whole
thing but some Republicans say that all
the coverage that corporate media
are giving Donald Trump is really
because they want to elect Hillary
Clinton and by giving him a lot of
coverage there's no way he can be
elected just based on what we've seen
well I mean there is no question that
MSNBC CNN and Fox have become Trump TV
there's no question of what reason
that's a very good question
for what reason they've done this but
certainly the statistics show that and
it's not just the network's it's the the
it's the newspapers what the Washington
Post from March 6th March 7th a 24 hour
period had 16 an T Sanders articles the
New York Times had a piece looking at
more recently had a piece looking at his
record ik+ piece looking at his record
in Congress and then it was changed by
an editor to be a negative piece and the
the public editor of the New York Times
then did a columns criticizing this but
the network's I mean you look at these
super Tuesday's one after the other
I remember one where the one where
Donald Trump was in his I call it White
House south right and one of his Florida
residences with all the American flags
behind him and he held a news conference
for an hour where he showed trumpeted if
you will Trump steaks Trump water Trump
magazines all the different Trump
products it went on for an hour now he
can hold it all night if he wants to but
the network's stayed with it now what
weren't they showing for this hour they
can do what they want but what weren't
they showing Hillary Clinton had given
her speech that night they recorded it
and they played it after so then you go
the next week or was two weeks later I
think it was Super Tuesday three this
was with Illinois Missouri this was very
contested five states she had won three
of them but it wasn't clear if she went
her home state and whether she'd win
Missouri it looked neck-and-neck very
close with Sanders she gave her speech
before that maybe not wanting to be
there after you know if she lost these
and that was a day Rubio pulled out they
showed Rubio that was Kasich that was
Ohio they showed his speech
they showed Ted Cruz of course I mean
they usually show all of the concession
or victory speeches and then they said
Ted they said that Donald Trump was
holding a news conference again it
didn't end up being a news conference
but it they just kept showing the empty
podium and they showed it and they
showed it and they were waiting and the
pundits were filling in they were
looking for something and then you
waited and finally they showed it and he
spoke for about half an hour and I was
at where was Bernie Sanders and all this
well The Huffington Post did a very good
piece at that moment saying where was
Bernie Sanders he was giving a speech to
thousands in Phoenix and it had started
before Donald Trump started why didn't
they go to that they can always cut away
if they have to but they never showed
Bernie Sanders at all that night at a
point when it was divided 3 to altom
Utley he would lose Missouri and
Illinois but where was this candidate
and the network's just brought you the
others but particularly I mean what the
Tyndall Center did a report in 2015 he
got 23 times more coverage than Bernie
Sanders and the network's make these
decisions he doesn't need to go to every
community because he's being he's being
channeled into everyone's home in a way
that others aren't and that has to be
challenged it's also why we need
independent media going to where what we
say the silences which by the way isn't
always so silent it's just that the
networks aren't shining their spotlights
there again go back to motivation take
the corporate media and why do they do
what they do and then go back to the
Republicans who think the corporate
media is trying to get Hillary Clinton
elected by covering Trump so much I
don't know if it's about getting Hillary
Clinton elected I mean I think you know
going way back I was on and I was
invited on the network sometimes I was
on MSNBC on one of the shows and I
remember it was very much at the
beginning I was saying that Bernie
Sanders and the person right before we
went to commercial during means that you
can't be serious I mean he's not going
anywhere well that's because if they're
not in communities understanding
people's enormous frustration there
isn't a sense of this because you don't
feel it in the hallowed halls of the of
the network studios you just don't feel
it why not they're not in touch
and they're making lots of money they
are and I think the reason that you
don't have a questioning of how money is
drowning politics drowning our democracy
is because these networks are making so
much money and especially in an election
year hands down you know the less
coverage they do the more the
politicians need to you know pay money
for their ads but they're furnishing
whole studios they're upgrading studios
because they're getting money from these
ads I think that is a huge problem I
think that campaigns shouldn't have to
raise money for ads they should have
some allotted time on television I mean
this has to all be worked out but that
way also because TV time is so expensive
these politicians wouldn't have to raise
this kind of money
which puts them in the pocket of the
corporations and the super PACs that
were there raising money from back to
democracy now how big organization is it
well you know we started on nine
stations there are in over fourteen
hundred stations our staff is a staff
based in New York City of about 25
full-time people and then volunteers
interns fellows and we've been doing
this for twenty years it has just been
astounding the growth working with
stations all over the country and
because we're on a lot of public
television and radio stations we do a
lot of fundraising for these days or
profit non profit non profit how much
does it cost you a year to function I
don't know the exact budget but it is
you know it is to cover the news all
over the world to maintain the staff but
I don't know the exact budget is it
going to be six seven million yes and
where do you get it
well a large part of it is listeners and
viewers some foundations for profit
nonprofit nonprofit this is a nonprofit
where nonprofit news organization and
maybe a station a week or every week or
two is picking up democracy
and it's absolutely amazing and it's
turned it's turned the population of
people who view public television really
on its head because it is a young
diverse audience people committed to
hearing voices like theirs and not like
theirs but where else do you get that on
television and radio here are two people
that you know well David Goodman and a
man that's also on the cover of your of
your book Denis Moynihan let's watch
them and I'll ask you about them I have
to say one of the most surprising things
and most moving things that happens
again and again when we go and speak in
rural areas and in places that are
traditionally conservative areas places
like Salt Lake City is soldiers and
their families come up and speak with us
many of them thank us we're bringing a
viewpoint that they are not getting and
many of them just come to express their
sense of what's going on so there's a
lot going on in the country you have to
get out there and cover it which is what
we try to do with democracy on which is
part of our goal with this hundred City
silenced majority election 2012 tour
really it at its heart are the the
wonderful constellation of community
media institutions that broadcast
democracy now with whom our work would
not be possible you don't say much about
it but isn't Dennis Monahan your husband
no he's not no no he is married but he
lives in Denver what a way that that is
that is stated somewhere on the internet
yeah somewhere on the Internet yes
that's why I'm asking you and I say at
universities and colleges in particular
you've got a double triple and quadruple
check everything that you see on the
internet David is my brother a great
journalist who lives in Vermont and
Dennis is my colleague at democracy now
who's been there since 2000 he lives in
Denver Colorado with his wife and
he has really helped to build democracy
now to what it is today we're about to
embark on a hundred city tour and as we
travel the country will be doing the
broadcast from wherever we are
we'll start in Ithaca New York and move
on to the Ohio State University that now
has the before it in Columbus Ohio
then we're moving on to st. Louis and
Kansas City and we'll be in Los Angeles
at the Los Angeles Times Book Festival
c-span covers these book festivals so
well we'll be doing fundraisers at so
many different community television and
radio stations we'll be moving on to San
Francisco to the San Francisco City Arts
and lecture series and going on to
Washington State New Mexico Houston
Texas Louisiana New Orleans Atlanta New
York all over what drives you the deep
commitment that independent media is the
oxygen of a democracy it's essential
holding those in power accountable you
know we're not there to serve some kind
of corporate agenda when we cover war
and peace we're not brought to you by
the weapons manufacturers when we cover
climate change we're not brought to you
by the oil the gas the coal companies
when we cover health care not by the
insurance industry and not by Big Pharma
but by individuals by viewers and
listeners who are deeply committed to
getting independent information so they
can make up their own minds they don't
have to agree with what they hear but
deeply believe in a forum for free
speech there's a fellow named John weir
do you know him I know what he did this
is back in 1991 and it's on YouTube got
a clip of him talking about when he
interrupted the Dan Rather evening news
show it's a longer clip than we can show
here but it's the whole thing's
available it's an interesting thing to
watch let's watch a little bit of this
where he talks about and sets up the
fact that he does interrupt the evening
news show back when in 1991
and we walk down the hall it was in the
middle of the war in the Gulf there were
all these people around it was quite a
mad scene that even noticed us walking
in and it's trying to look like
television executives and we stroll down
the hall with our fake IDs and stood by
the side and waited for the show to
start and as soon as Dan Rather said
good evening Dale and Daryl and I were
on the set and jumping from the camera
and what happened was that my face pops
into the screen and the lower left hand
side of the screen for about three
seconds I saw they are in video just
John John wears head going and we were
chatting on Fridays not Arabs apologize
to you for the way that broadcast came
on the air tonight there were some rude
people here they tried to stage a
demonstration
they've been ejected mr. vo but our
apologies for the way we began our
coverage of the Gulf War will continue
after these messages
fight AIDS not Arabs I mean this is a
such a powerful movement which we
document in our book democracy now
twenty years covering the movements
changing America the movement fighting
AIDS and not Arabs you know act up the
AIDS coalition to unleash power the
bravery of young people who were facing
this calamity you know recently Hillary
Clinton was congratulating Nancy Reagan
after you know eulogizing her talking
about her after she died recently
talking about her brave stance and AIDS
but had to take this back
it was sadly President Reagan did not
mention aids in his first term or
halfway through his second term I think
into a seventh year even though this is
when the epidemic was raging and so then
you understand when you have a media
that's so often just covers power and
the power the powerful the president was
not addressing aids people on the ground
and their communities were dying
this young population
taken down why if they could put
centerstage this epidemic and how it was
happening and putting money into
research to deal with it and so you had
people like John we're I mean it didn't
only happen on CBS when they interrupted
the Dan Rather Newshour
it also happened on PBS on the NewsHour
they dealt with it a little bit
differently and said we will discuss
this issue but they were taking they
understood how powerful media is to get
out a message and so they took it into
their own hands when I run just another
clip of John we're because it I want to
ask you the question is what is it about
some people that would go and interrupt
a newscast like this where does that
start in life but it's watch this it
turns out that um as a matter of fact my
father works for television my father
works for NBC TV which is a rival
network I was on CBS my father's job at
NBC TV he's retired now but for 35 years
his job was basically to be left to take
care of all he was basically the vice
president of cut to black when activists
invade you studio he was like in charge
of technical foul ups and whenever
anything went wrong they called my
father so essentially when I leaked in
front of the TV camera it was it was
John leaping into dad's TV studio studio
and dad pulling the plug so he took it
personally and my mother's father ran a
radio station in Denver he was a manager
of the radio station in Denver during
the war my brother is a video editor yet
it's for NBC Nightly News he did at the
time he edited the Olympics in Barcelona
and Solo in Korea he has Emmy Awards and
it was basically as if I had violated
the family temple you know even whether
you agree or disagree watching the whole
thing on YouTube is an interesting
experience so if somebody wants to see
the whole thing but what is it look
listen to that family and this man for
some reason rather was quite willing to
break all the codes and jump in front of
the camera you don't think it was for
some reason or other it was because this
community was being guess
and made it his friends were dying this
is nothing compared to that
and what was something was letting this
country know and when they saw millions
of dollars now billions of dollars being
put into war to kill people but not to
save people here who are suffering from
this epidemic not being talked about he
decided to take action himself and it's
very important to be able to weather as
you said you agree with it or not to
hear why people do something I think
about Scott Olson who is a young marine
who served two tours of duty in Iraq
this is sort of advancing much further
now into the Iraq and Afghanistan wars
and he came back to the United States
and he ended up being on the frontlines
of protests in Oakland at Occupy Oakland
here was this former soldier and there
are many veterans and former soldiers
who have been a part of the Occupy
movement and he got shot in the head by
a beanbag projectile of the Oakland
police they almost killed him when
unconscious people around him didn't
know him went to pick him up and they
were hit with a flash grenade the group
that went to save him right in front of
the police because the police didn't
want this gathering in front of them a
horrific story but Scott just stood by
his values when he regained
consciousness ultimately came out of the
hospital he was part in 2012 of the anti
NATO summit in Chicago this is very
interesting what happened
scores of soldiers marched and they
threw their medals back like what
happened back in the early 70s with John
Kerry when he came back from the Vietnam
War they did the same throwing their
medals back and these soldiers in 2012
two of the reporters that can't with
democracy now is there and did a number
of shows on this but two of the
reporters that went to cover it was
Haskell Wexler the
rates than a photographer who recently
died like at the age of 93 who did
medium cool and amazing filmmaker and a
young reporter named James Foley James
Foley who of course is well known to
everyone because he ultimately was
beheaded by Isis he went back to Syria
after covering the Santee NATO protests
and he was one Jim Foley who deeply
believed in hearing people's voices on
the ground that perhaps too he covered
war to end war and he felt that the
people of Syria's voices were not being
heard he had already been held hostage
in Libya he came here to cover the peace
movement and he went back to cover the
people on the ground who were the
victims of war and he ultimately would
face the ultimate penalty for what he
did and he was beheaded by Isis you know
they his family I just interviewed at
the Sundance Film Festival with his
close friend Brian Oakes who who made a
film about him called Jim the James
Foley's story it's very interesting to
follow independent journalists to see
the paths they take you had a
responsibility of being the president
United States and you were facing what
the last two presidents have faced what
would you have done differently I mean I
came to the war Iraq war Afghanistan war
I mean not go to war I mean and that
what would you do about protecting the
American people is well I mean I think
what was shown at the time was that
Saddam Hussein did not have weapons of
mass destruction he was not an imminent
threat to the United States and even
what Tony Blair the prime minister who
sided with George W Bush and committed
forces to Iraq he was just interviewed
by Fareed Zakaria on CNN and asked what
do you say to those who say that this
you know invasion of Iraq would
ultimately lead to the formation of Isis
and he said and that that is partly true
but you go back to the 9/11 situation
you were on the scene down there was it
a half
stance that you were that close to we
were the closest national broadcast to
ground zero we operated out of a hundred
year old firehouse at the time September
11th 2001 was election day in New York
it was a primary day and we were doing
the broadcast at that time we were in
the garret and we couldn't see what was
happening outside we broadcast then at
nine o'clock now we broadcast live at 8
a.m. at democracynow.org and on stations
around the country but then at 9:00 at
8:47 the first plane hit the first Tower
of the World Trade Center we didn't know
what had happened outside we were just
down the street we were within the
evacuation zone 903 the second plane hit
we were doing a special that day and the
connection between terror and September
11 1973 the day Salvador Allende the
president in Chile died in the palace as
the Pinochet forces rose to power sadly
the US backed Nixon back Kissinger back
Pinochet forces rose to power in Chile
Pinochet would ultimately take control
seventeen-year rein killed thousands of
Chileans and other Latin Americans
that's what we were looking at on
September 11th and this happened we just
continued to broadcast on September 11th
2001
the firehouse was opened up it was a
decommissioned firehouse and they were
providing water to people phones so they
could call their families we were just
interviewing people as they came in
through the day and broadcast to whoever
was taking our broadcast and then we
stayed inside the firehouse for the next
days because we were within the
evacuations evacuation zone and I felt
if we went outside I was afraid that the
police would force us out because that's
what they were doing to people in that
area but it was critical to keep on
broadcasting because what was being
projected to the rest of the world the
reaction I think was very different from
what was happening on the ground people
streaming into parks holding candles
comforting each other it was not a cry
for war in fact there was a little
sticker that artists against war put out
all over that said our grief is not a
cry for war
and I think that much more express the
sentiment we were interviewing people
like the late great historian Howard
Zinn who wrote people's history of the
United States was saying we should be
sending nurses and doctors into
Afghanistan not soldiers imagine how the
world would respond differently you know
what happened on September 11th was
horrific 3,000 people incinerated in an
instant will actually never know how
many people died on that day because
those who go and counted in life go
uncounted and death and they're the
undocumented workers and folks who lived
in that area or work there so as we
watch Isis grow do you suggest that that
was caused by us I mean I think it is
many people feel including those like
Tony Blair including you've heard the
president refer to this that you are
seeing a growth of a force that came out
of the destabilization of Iraq I mean
Saddam was saying there's no question he
was a tyrant but he was not a threat to
the United States and also how did he
stay in power for so long this tyrant
who is oppressive to his own people I
mean remember that handshake of Donald
Rumsfeld and Saddam Hussein as the US
was providing support and financial
support for Saddam Hussein under George
HW Bush my colleague Jeremy Scahill did
a great job with showing this and
showing that image so for a long time
the US was supporting Iraq and Saddam
Hussein then they turn against Saddam
Hussein he didn't have weapons of mass
destruction why weren't we waiting for
the UN weapons inspectors who were
saying wait I mean Hans Blix
and others saying wait let us do our
work but President Bush was intent on
attacking Iraq from almost the minute
give it a day or two after September
11th I mean you hear his national
security for the you know his national
security czar and others saying he was
talking about Iraq when we understood
full well this wasn't coming from there
I mean another issue
that is a kind of sacred cow with the
media that must be challenged is the
questioning of Saudi Arabia and the role
that it has played over the years I mean
if you ask most people who was in those
planes that were that went into the
World Trade Center you would think given
the response of the United States that
it was Iraqis 15 of the 19 hijackers
were from Saudi Arabia and what did
President Bush do at the time you know
he's on the Truman balcony smoking a
cigar with the Saudi ambassador to the
United States within a few days and what
are they doing when all planes are
grounded this fully documented what's
the motive then of george w bush gay
relationship to the saudis i mean well
they were intent at the time an
attacking Iraq there is a joke of a
little boy saying to his father what's
our oil doing under their sand it's not
our oil what's the motive if you're a
George W Bush do you really want to go
to war do you want to really want to see
our own Americans killed over there I
mean what's what's the reason it's a
very good question why president george
w bush why Vice President Cheney why
Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld why
they committed so many innocent lives in
this country think about the soldiers
who went to Iraq deeply committed to
securing the United States why were they
sent to Iraq that is a very serious
question you know interestingly one of
the people who signed up to be in the
military who ultimately wasn't was
Edward Snowden one of the great
whistleblowers of our time he ended up
having both as his legs were broken and
training and he didn't go into the
military ended up working with the NSA
but had a deep commitment to the United
States and ended up showing it in a
different way was perspective though why
do you think I mean I was Don Rumsfeld
and George W Bush Paul Wolfowitz were
they evil people I mean
when you look at the actions they
engaged in were they evil actions
committing so many lives leading to the
loss of not only American lives but
lives in Iraq and Afghanistan it's
horrific what has happened and we are
talking why do you think what motivated
them to do it I mean that's the question
that's never been answered and obviously
you were against it from the beginning
and you demonstrated before it even
started but what's the reason matter of
saying what would be the reason after
the September 11th attacks when we were
harmed so seriously we would attack a
country who had nothing to do with the
September 11th attacks I do not know why
they were so intent on taking out Saddam
Hussein from Iraq there are many
dictators in the world except the
countries that we target are so often
have precious resources the US wants to
control for example like oil but I think
it is more complicated than that all we
can look at and all we can judge is the
actions that they took why in their
hearts I can't tell you okay but in a
democracy your leaders are chosen by the
people he was reelected in 2004 so the
public must not have been unhappy well
you know that's another interesting
issue our elections and when we started
democracy now in 1996 in the end of 1995
I was in Haiti why was it that people
and covering East Timor people would go
to the polls risk their lives but in the
United States and in many countries in
the world the vast majority of people
vote in the United States most people do
not vote who are eligible or it's like
50% or slightly higher I mean this is a
very serious issue when we look at why
people don't vote I think there are many
obstacles put in their path and there's
the question of whether they feel
there's a real choice but we have to
look at why people are elected with like
25 percent of the vote which is
something like along the lines
of what George W Bush was elected by so
what happens when Amy Goodman says it's
time to quit
how does democracy now continue Oh
democracy now is a group of deeply
committed journalists and producers and
I co-host with different people and work
with journalists all over the country
and around the world democracy now is
much bigger than me
but still you're the one that conceived
it and you're the one that's hosted it
I'm the founding host of democracy now
but it will continue because I mean
there is a new generation of journalists
and reporters who are deeply committed
to independent media we are part of an
independent media movement in this
country and around the world that's much
bigger than any one institution looking
back 20 years where were the different
points along the way where you thought
this might not work
I or you I didn't think that or there
was a hiccup I didn't think that from
the beginning we originally began with
Pacifica Radio then we went independent
and we stood we also expand it to
television as well and it has just
continued to grow I mean I think being
out in this country and around the world
that hunger for independent voices has
is just enormous so that wasn't really
something I thought from the beginning
so what can get in your way now from
this moment forward who are you
dependent on besides the money to keep
you going in other words satellite dish
TV carries you Brown we yes we're on
public radio public television community
radio stations public access TV stations
on both satellite networks on edition
Network free speech TV and Lenk TV on
both DirecTV and Dish Network and then
around the world I mean we pioneered a
way to send and this was because at the
time you know the networks would spend
millions I mean even in Saddam Hussein's
Iraq they would pay a millions of
dollars to use the satellites now we
couldn't afford satellites like that and
so we pioneered a way to send broadcast
quality video way back
through the internet so that we could
send it to stations all over and now of
course that's commonplace how they get
it on the they get it to satellite but
net now we use satellites as well so we
use every means necessary to get
information out and you know the
Internet is also something we have to
fight for to remain open and free and
not to allow the video companies and any
of the corporate networks to rewrite the
rules of the internet so that it's
privatized it's something that was
developed with public resources and it's
the great equalizer it's the way we can
talk with each other all over the world
so somebody might have listened this
last hour and said you know Amy Goodman
is really not a lot different than a
United States Senator she just has a
different platform I'm a journalist
and I but what what is a journalist a
journalist is well I can just say that
would I do you know I started as a young
person and my nan elementary school but
junior high school in high school
covering what was happening in our
school the principal and then I just
took it to a larger stage beyond that
and it's being there chronicling what's
happening digging deep going beyond that
he said she said to look at what's
happening in the world chronicling it it
is not just a matter of different
perspective some part of this is just
being a forum for people to speak for
themselves and another part is digging
deep to get at the truth and this issue
of holding those in power accountable is
essential that's why independent media
is essential to any democracy and I hope
we can be a model for people and
institutions around the country so often
we have documentary makers coming from
all over the planet to chronicle
democracy now to show a model that isn't
state media isn't corporate media that
is truly independent get one minute in
ten years what do you think you would be
saying about the journalism of this
country
hopefully independent media will be the
par for the course that it will be
accepted that it's unusual that you have
weapons manufacturers oil companies and
insurance industries running the
essential check on power that instead it
would be an outgrowth of the democracy
saying we need independent bodies that
are monitoring and holding those in
power our guest has a book out called
democracy now it's 20 years covering the
movements changing America along with
her brother David Goodman and her friend
Dennis morning thank you very much thank
you so much Brian
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts if you enjoyed this
week's Q&A interview with Amy Goodman
here are some other programs you might
like radio talk show host bill press
talks about his book buyer's remorse
how Obama led progressives down artist
and author Molly crabapple on her
drawings of the israeli-palestinian
conflict and the Guantanamo detention
center and radio talk show host Hugh
Hewitt on his book the happiest life you
can watch these anytime or search our
entire video library at c-span org
c-span's Washington Journal live every
day with news and policy issues that
impact you coming up Monday morning Mara
Keisling executive director for the
National Center for transgender equality
on the reaction of the transgender
community to the North Carolina bathroom
law and then columnist for Halle
politics Indiana
Craig done on Tuesday's Republican
Indiana primary and now the Cruz Kasich
Alliance is playing out in the Hoosier
State be sure to watch these bands
Washington journal beginning live at
7:00 a.m. Eastern Monday morning
join the discussion during this week's
question time British Prime Minister
David Cameron acknowledged the
anniversary of the Hillsborough disaster
which killed 96 soccer fans in 1989 he
also answered questions on the refugee
crisis anti-semitism in the House of
Commons and the UK's education system
this is about 30